we're joined by Angus Robertson from the
SNP cabinet secretary for the
Constitution external Affairs and
culture in Scotland good morning Mr
Robertson
morning Trevor thank you for joining us
now Nicola sturgeons complained this
week that Liz trust hasn't been in touch
um is that still true
I believe so yeah
and um just as a matter of interest uh
why doesn't she just pick up the phone
and call Liz Truss
well I think the first Minister did
speak in passing to Liz truss at the
funeral for her majesty at the queen but
it's common custom and practice when
somebody takes up office this is what
happened with
um both Boris Johnson and uh his
predecessor that they got in touch with
the first Ministers of both Scotland and
Wales on assuming office within days of
doing so that's what happened then
that's not what's happening now and it's
disappointing and frankly a bit childish
well yeah but you know Nicholas
surgeon's been there a lot longer than
Liz truss
um wouldn't it be a bit grown up for her
to she knows Liz trust just ring up and
say um when are we going to have a chat
I just told you that she did speak to
her
um what it is is that issue is that the
Prime Minister who if you remember made
great play of suggesting that she would
ignore the first minister of Scotland is
ignoring the first minister of Scotland
is ignoring the first minister of Wales
and that's not supposed to how it's
supposed to work okay a multinational
State we're supposed to have grown-up
relations uh which is exactly why the
first Minister did speak to the new
prime minister at the Queen's uh funeral
unfortunately the Prime Minister hasn't
found time yet to speak to the first
Ministers of Scotland or Wales since
assuming office had time to speak to a
lot of other people
okay this is uh forgive me this might be
a little confusing for viewers she has
spoken to her or she has not spoken to
her what what would you have they spoken
or have they spoken to the
the first minister of Scotland spoken
passing to the prime minister at the
funeral of her majesty the queen that's
what I said a moment ago what's normal
when a prime minister takes office is
that they call
um the leaders of governments and
countries with whom they have a valued
relationship that's the normal custom
and practice and the prime minister of
the United Kingdom has not seen fit to
speak to the first Ministers of Scotland
or Wales at any great length since
taking office which is odd given that a
unionist a unionist politician who says
that the respect agenda between the UK
government and the different nations of
the United Kingdom it doesn't think that
it's we're speaking to the leaders of
Scotland or Wales okay I okay I I
understand the point is that uh uh Miss
sturgeon feels she hasn't been spoken to
with at the right time and with
sufficient respect and uh at same length
now one of the things that they could
have talked about then would have been
uh the state of the economy and what you
do about it together
um can you just make clear what what is
the Scottish government's point of view
on the basic rate of income tax will it
be uh agreeing with the UK government
that the basic rate should come down to
19
P which is uh in the Scottish
government's purview you can decide
whether it goes with it or doesn't what
what are you going to do
so the first so the the first thing that
the Scottish government would do is tell
the UK government that it has made a
huge mistake with its approach to the UK
economy crashing the currency driving
debt through the roof
um leading to uncertainty in the markets
that is driving mortgage rates up which
will make mortgage payments of far too
many people length and breadth of the UK
unaffordable so
um launching a Kamikaze budget at the
beginning of a term of office is
certainly not something that the SNP
would be supporting and from the start
we have said that especially in relation
to the tax cuts to the rich whether it's
the 45p rate or whether it's the bankers
bonuses and that's exactly the wrong way
to go in terms of other tax changes
Deputy first Minister John Swinney um
has called together experts who will be
advising him with a report before the
end of this month when we have to make
decisions about what we will be doing
with tax rates in Scotland you're
absolutely right to highlight that we do
have we do have marginal um controls
over taxation in Scotland and at that
point the right decisions would be made
but we would certainly not have been
emulating and the Very damaging approach
that the UK Tory government has been
making uh towards the economy in
Scotland and the rest of the UK
so if you if your view is that you do
not want to copy what um the trust
government is doing it is quite possible
that um come April Scots will be paying
more in income tax than everybody else
in the UK
I'm sure you'd want to finish off that
sentence by pointing out the fact of
yours in the rest of the UK that
taxpayers in Scotland in general the
majority pay less tax across the piece
than the rest of the United Kingdom
those are the facts as they stand we are
trying to find the appropriate balance
in government policy to no no no no no
no no no
sorry I didn't
just okay let me sorry sorry you didn't
you didn't clarify you didn't I'm sorry
you've responded on the total tax tag
the question I really I asked was that
the individual in Scotland would be
paying a higher basic rate than others
in the UK
and I as I said and and not incorrect to
point this out the majority of taxpayers
in Scotland pay less tax than the rest
of the United Kingdom that is the
context at the present time I also said
just a moment ago that Deputy first
Minister John Sweeney who's in in charge
of the public finances at this present
time in Scotland is reviewing the impact
of the UK government's
um mini budget to work out what the
appropriate decisions should be in
Scotland and would we do it on the basis
of the facts unlike the UK government
that has been making very damaging
decisions without the advice of the
office of budget responsibility we are
going to make decisions about Scotland's
finances in a prudent way but there's a
wide-appointed issue with this Trevor
which is Scotland doesn't need to be in
this situation we don't need to have our
public finances decided upon by people
that we have not elected since 1955. we
of course have another option and we
voted in favor of that in last year's
Scottish Parliament election name namely
to have a referendum in this country so
that we can become an independent state
and rejoin the European Union I would
far rather not be at the mercy of Tory
chancellors of the exchequer or prime
ministers who we haven't voted for it's
not sustainable and it's not sensible
given everything that we've learned
about their financial imprudence and
their belief in a thatcherite and
economic Orthodoxy which is going to
cost us all dearly all right let's move
away from the things that um for which
as you would put it the Tories are
responsible and let's talk about the
things which you do all by yourself so
for example
um there's supposed to be an inquiry
into covid in Scotland can you tell us
when that's going to start and by the
way can you tell us why the chair and I
think three
um Junior count three four councils uh
have resigned from that inquiry
so in in Scotland we have a separation
of powers government is separate from
the legal system so it's not for me to
speak on behalf of
um Scottish judges or Scottish Advocates
about an inquiry that is separate from
government you'll have to arrange to
speak to people in Scotland's legal
system for those kind of questions we
value the separation of government and
our judicial system and it's going to
remain that way
uh Professor Peter Watson who represents
the families of those who lost uh loved
ones says
this inquiry is going nowhere it's
commissioned by the Scottish government
uh surely you do have some
responsibility for it
well I would wish it could be underway
and I would wish that it would report as
quickly as possible the lessons need to
be learned and as you quite rightly say
families want answers they deserve that
I'm pointing out a big basic fact about
the the way government and the way our
judicial system works in in this country
it's not for us to intervene in
Personnel decisions about independent
legal inquiries of course I I I hope
that it is up and running as quickly as
possible I hope that it can conclude as
quickly as possible and it's a shame
that things are not underway those
questions though are rightly to be
addressed um at our legal authorities
who are very separate from government
and quite rightly so and in the meantime
if there's any way that government can
help whilst protecting the independence
of our our legal system to get on with
the inquiry that we would all want to
see conclude we would be happy to do
that all right well let's try and talk
about something for which you and only
you are responsible which is what you
say about Indie ref 2 the the first
Minister said this week that if you
don't get a favorable judgment from the
Supreme Court that you will treat the
general election as a vote on
Independent now some people might say
that's just a tad arrogant isn't it for
the voters to decide what a general
election is about
well let's just remind ourselves what
the voters actually decided and we had
an election last year where this was the
number one issue in the election people
voted in the voted in record numbers for
a pro-independence government in the
Scottish Parliament at the parties that
were elected on a Manifesto com
commitment that the people should be
able to decide in the referendum won the
election and the parties that oppose
that the concerns with
respects
greatest Trevor you were forever
how do you know that that was the number
one issue for the great
with the greatest well I I was in the
middle of the election campaign I had
the Good Fortune to win the seat uh that
Ruth Davidson previously held as the
leader of the Scottish conservative
party in Edinburgh Central I know very
well why I won that election I know what
was in my Manifesto and the people not
knew what was in the SNP manifest I'm
not a patronize the electorate the
electorate uh voted for a
pro-independence majority in the
Parliament and to Simply do as if that
doesn't matter
um frankly it's not good enough in in a
democracy and when you have guests on
programs and ask them whether they will
respect democratic election results to
Simply pass on from it when they they
say no we're not going to respect a
democracy is frankly slightly odd in my
view it is remarkable how UK political
parties that lost the election Scotland
in this issue are given a pass on this
either we live in a democracy or we
don't the people have voted to have the
right to choose and in a democracy the
people should be able to choose they can
vote Yes they can vote no but surely
they should have the right to choose we
can solve this issue very simply because
we managed to do it in the run-up to
2014 the UK government respected the
election result in Scotland they passed
what was called a section 30 order and
we were able to hold a referendum in
Scotland there is no impediment to this
happening the fact that we've had to go
to the Supreme Court the fact that we're
having to invoke the possibility of
using elections to yet again show that
people want to choose on this country's
future is not where we need to be at far
rather the UK government just respected
the Scottish electorate respected the um
the election result and the majority of
the Scottish Parliament and as good
Democrats as Democrats abide by
Democratic standards unfortunately the
conservatives and now sadly also the
labor party are perfectly happy to
discard Scottish democracy and it's not
good enough okay
Angus Robertson thank you so much for
for joining us this morning